foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
everybody
[Music]
[Music]
thank you all right
[Music]
yo what up everybody it is week 13 and
we are back I'm feeling good I don't
know about y'all but I'm feeling good
because we cash the CFB parlay last
night the college football parlay last
night Championship parlay you know I let
it off Ryan you always give me gripe I
let it off and I lost I lost I'll be
honest I lost accountability but you
know what happens you know what happens
when you have a team you know and
somebody falls down guess what happens
the rest of the team picks that person
up in my team Natalie Bryson and Michael
Bolin picked me up and we all cast
because we all put money on that right
Sam you put money on it right oh yeah
man team wins damn put money Ryan you
put money we all put money it so we all
cast I'm feeling good how y'all feeling
on this week 13.
amazing and uh I have a sneaky suspicion
we're gonna build another you know we're
parlay guys we just hit every week now I
feel like we're gonna we're gonna build
another one on this show
uh oh Sam's getting to it let me welcome
everybody to the show welcome to the
show once again my name is Greg Ivory
next to me is Sam the man the myth the
legend Richmond and next to him is
producer
Ryan he is the man that links us to you
guys he's the chat Whisperer uh we're
going to give out our best best drop
your locks in the chat please drop those
lots in the chat because we'll be
grading those picks at the end of the
show but right now right now we need
your help to build out another anytime
touchdown parlay because we hit last
week right we we we're we're on the up
we're on the up we did not hit right
Brian's not gonna like that Ryan's we
didn't we didn't hit last week but you
know if we added Christian Watson I'm
not I listened I I said this last week
I'm not and I Told You So guy so I'm not
gonna say I told you so but I think
Christian Watson was brought up and I
did say if he scored I would be
unbearable but I'm I woke up this
morning and I said I'm gonna take the
high road so I'm not gonna talk did you
hit your parlay no it's your version no
I didn't okay so then why are you
talking because that's what I'm because
I didn't say
take my entire parlay I said just take
my advice the chat wants Christian
Watson I thought it was a good play hey
one of yeah whatever Kenneth Walker
scored twice you don't get money for him
scoring twice wait he wait Greg did you
win your fantasy matchup last week
that's important of course of course I
won the Fantasy matchup last week
Kenneth Walker did me right did me
Justice I'm I'm not in the parlay though
he did do justice in the parlay wasn't
it your pick or one of the picks that
you were pushing that didn't win no Mark
Andrews dropped the ball in the end zone
and Christian and Christian McCaffrey
you said God told you Christian
McCaffrey was gonna score
oh my God let us down last week
all right that's so funny bro
I did have a dream
that was the best handicap of all time I
can't believe that didn't hit
hey Ryan come on bro
chette comments
La built
to somebody dropped a good question that
we were actually talking about before
the show is Maddie 2X
asked if uh sauce is gonna shut down
Justin Jefferson today oh that that is a
good place for us to start because I
think if people have watched this show
they would assume that Justin Jefferson
would be the first leg of our parlay
because Greg has a theory that's been
pretty bulletproof that you take Justin
Jefferson every time he's plus money but
today he is going against arguably like
I think you make a very fair case that
sauce Gardner is the best cornerback in
the sport right now I don't think that's
crazy to say
um so that is going to be just an
electric match-up and yeah I would I
would like to give Greg the floor to see
if he can make a case for us to take
Jessica Jefferson because Eileen no I'm
I'm scared I do not want to go against
sauce I mean let's be honest let's like
let's be honest here what are we talking
about like we have a strategy that we've
been going that we've been going with
the whole year and it's been leading us
to you know into the plus side
he's going against a rookie
he's going against a rookie I personally
think one-on-one nobody in this league
can guard Justin Jefferson and I I I'll
put like
I wish we can set up a tournament
nobody can guard Justice Jefferson
except Trayvon Diggs exactly the Cowboys
d-line except yeah except the Cowboys
defensive line yeah the Cowboys
defensive line was was made uh my man JJ
Limited in that game he Kirk Cousins
only threw the ball for 105 yards right
he only glue the ball for 105. yeah he
didn't have any time Trayvon takes
nothing to do with that
absolutely nothing to do with that but
uh let's let's let's JJ JJ's plus money
guys I like I think I don't think he
can't get guarded but we'll leave it I'm
gonna get out in front of this because I
know where Ryan stands on this issue I
and I know where you standing such a
great I think we need to let the chat
decide that one for us
is in or out so I don't know if we can
run like a rapid fire pole or if you
just need to like or if the chat should
just like Slam in there like JJ yes JJ
no but maybe we put a pin on that one
let the chat decide okay okay so uh
well yeah we'll let the chat decide on
that one I'm also a big proponent of
maybe adding some more juice to this
parlay and we have a good take uh
Hardbody Craig says I'm in Ross Saint
Brown a must today against the Jags
so if we go down to that
I like that almond rise plus 100. I
don't hate that
I like that
yes we need vibes from the chat though
vibes from the chat thumbs up Ryan but
let's let's put it in the parlay for now
so people could see it
thumbs up in the chat if you guys like
uh this pick thumbs down in the chat if
you guys don't like this pick and we'll
just uh we'll just keep going I'm just
looking through right now his his recent
games 10 targets eight targets 11
targets nine targets ten targets he he's
getting a lot of looks and yeah he's
he's a machine I also think there's
gonna be a ton of points in that game
me too bro me too Ryan yeah look at us
we're on the same page
we have to take it we have it also we're
getting Good Vibes Good Vibes in the
comments from TB comedy he says Amara is
cooking right now so Good Vibes are
coming from the comments and I'm also
seeing some thumbs up fellas
yes sir I like that
um can I throw out a boring one unless
we have a good suggestion from the chat
when you say boring do you mean it's
gonna be like minus 200 yeah
Derrick Henry is going to is minus 145
so it's not minus 200 but like that
Eagles Rush defense is a poverty Rush
defense Derek Henry is the entire
offense he is going to wear them down
they're going to give them all 30 times
I would just be very surprised if he
doesn't find the end zone so I'm just
going out there Jordan Davis Jordan
Davis back
doesn't scare you no I I that defense I
mean like it helps it definitely helps
but there's still like 25th even when
they had him so no I'm not I'm not too
concerned okay Sam I like I like it Ryan
it'll hit I like it yeah like the the
offense of the Titans is Derrick Henry
like they literally feed that man the
ball
oon
yeah I was gonna say that let's plug it
in let's plug it in Ryan let's just put
it in the parlay we're gonna ask the
chat if they like it give us thumbs up
if they don't like it give us thumbs
down it seems like they like the uh the
same the same uh Omron uh yeah so got a
lot of thumbs up for the Sun God and
then I would assume that we like Derrick
Henry we'll wait for the chat to see if
they if they give us thumbs up but again
I'm gonna I'm going to push this
propaganda until we embrace it we are at
two picks this is going to be a three
pick parlay we are currently at Plus
237. for the love of God somebody drop a
plus 180 at least play
Ryan yeah this is not this is not your
parlay no it's not my parlay but it's
not my parlay but we can't do another
three-legger that's like plus 400. but
like Ryan Greg
Sam respect to Henry NJ Reese NJ Reese
is in the comments and saying as an
Eagles fan
Henry is scoring okay all right well so
then that's what I like to hear yeah but
it's also I just like I just don't love
the bad like Ryan we're parlay guys we
build them we hit everything we are
betting is hit a parlay like a month in
a row it's not bad vibes it's just like
we need to start thinking a little bit
more like this is three legs imagine if
we hit one that was like 12 to 1 10 to
one
we were Legends I love the aspirations I
love the aspirations I'm a big
aspiration guy but the people has to
choose this is the people's parlay the
people in the comments giving a lot of
thumbs up to Sam's Derek Henry thick
okay look you are a man of the of the
chat
I'm seeing stuff right now I think
though next week I think we need to
build a community anytime 2D parlot and
then we need to have like Ryan's Hail
Mary parlay so Ryan can get all of his
like craziness out so we'll build two
parlays Ryan can throw together some
[ __ ] Harley that's not gonna hit and
then
it's not gonna hit absolutely hey let's
do that let's do that let's do it 51
parlay right we can make a side Bend we
can make a side bed on the side that
like
you don't hit in two weeks that I don't
hit oh okay we will talk later but yes I
would I would definitely take that we
might can make it three weeks all right
guys Charlie is gonna be like Noah gray
and Trent Taylor and Tommy Trimble you
guys hate tight ends I don't know why
you hate tight ends all right let's get
back to the chat okay uh King Ang says
Garrett Wilson touchdown he scored two
last week with Mike White and the
Vikings pass defense stinks fast defense
made Mac Jones look like the [ __ ] yes
uh excuse my language
um looks like the greatest Showman
let's go see what it is this is what I
asked for Plus 175.
okay
I mean tell the chat I'm sorry for using
foul language
yeah we'll see if they forgive you Ryan
I mean I'm down to plug it in and let
the chat decide
um but I I'm just saying I also see a
lot of AJ Brown in the chat
um we already have one from that game
these might be Philly fans I know I know
Ryan
this is the people's parlay this is
okay we need to win today okay I I have
been on a losing streak we need to win
we do need to win you're not lying about
that oh oh hold on hold on guys I'm
sorry I just see an interesting one and
I just want you guys to take I see uh
babe boy 99 Keenan Allen plus 150 Ryan
this is in your territory yes I mean
like borderline but plus one to 50.
let me wear all right Chargers
do we get any Vibe checks what are we if
we're gonna give if we're gonna give
takes in the chat drop the right odds I
dropped I dropped this down and we see
Keenan Allen plus 110. that's a fat no
for me I I don't know what you're what
your take is guys but Keenan Allen plus
110 it'd be a miracle if you finish the
game
this guy's got a hamstring the Raiders
he's playing that's money I'm not gonna
lie Keenan Allen is money
last week I think Ryan's point is fair
like is he still on a snap count how
many targets he's gonna get like no
doubt he's super talented Mike Williams
out helps but let's see how he got seven
hamstrings than Keenan not bad seven
targets not bad
I don't hate I don't hate Michael Bolin
is in the comments saying Keenan Allen
everybody baith boy is saying yes
I don't know guys uh spicy sponge Keenan
Allen lock okay hold on be Keenan Saint
Brown and Derek Henry what were the odds
for that be let's just let's just
visualize it Keenan
I'm trying to get in like the plus 450
500 why sweet spot because look at what
we did last night we hit that last night
when we had that exactly I'm not
discounting what we did last night we
all we all won last night I'm I'm very
happy for us but 600 is too high we need
to add in another minus two hunting I
was kidding
yes when you're doing these the people
want wins that's what they care about
they care about winning I'm trying to
think I'm trying to be like oh you guys
lost but you went for big so like
congratulations no they're gonna tell us
we suck and we're the Biggest Losers of
all time we gotta win to keep these
people off our backs exactly I listen I
I'm trying to give a voice to the chat
here uh twin number two said cold commit
plus 230. I saw it was Jefe X said TJ
Hawkinson you guys know I love TJ
Hawkinson and Tommy Bronx said Justin
Fields I don't know why we're so why are
we so hung up on Kina now in a plus 110.
if we were to say take Keaton Allen out
and this is just you know obviously
hypothetical if we were to take him out
and then go to TJ Hawkinson and we're at
plus 846
or hypothetically take him out and then
go to Coal commit or Justin Fields I
mean what would that be
Ryan no lie you're getting some love
only one person though but they're
they're saying let Ryan let Ryan Cook
not opposed I'm not opposed to letting
Ryan put it not coconut and Ryan wants
to put Hawkinson in there
and then it's a win-win either way you
hit the parlay because Derek Henry and
Saint Brad are gonna score or we can
just get the flame Ryan next week so I'm
I'm fine I'm with it I'm with it we can
add Hopkinton all right let's first off
guys this is the people's parlays it's
not but this is I didn't say TJ
Hawkinson they said TJ Hawkinson okay
okay okay so let's ask the people put uh
put in TJ Hawkinson Ryan yeah there it
is uh the odds are Plus what's that 8 46
846. you guys like the TJ Hawkinson pick
we need thumbs up in the comments we
also need thumbs down if you guys do not
like the big
if you guys don't like the pick put
Keenan Allen next to the thumbs down so
we can know what we should actually ride
with I was actually this is a good
comment here which I do think is fair is
that Hawkinson could be the focus if you
know JJ is kind of getting a lot you
know I don't hate it I don't I don't
hate it that's a good take dare I say a
great take problem Action Jackson so
shout out to them action and I'm
assuming he's a big Lamar guy I'm the
world's biggest Lamar guy so that's
that's good vibes uh Vish Patel liked uh
Henry almond Ron Garrett Wilson uh so I
it seems like it's gonna come down to
picking somebody from this game hold on
hey Ryan the chat is killing Ryan do you
see the chat you are the man of the chat
you should look at the chat and see what
they're saying hey yo what's with the
thumbs down
also if we're gonna give a thumbs down
can we give a thumbs down and then give
a recommendation like it's the easiest
thing in the world to say no I don't
like that but it's harder to come with
your own lock I'm trying to do this Bob
and weave let's just do this go ahead
put put Keith and Alan back in there put
Keenan Allen back in there and let's
let's do the same thing let's ask the
chat if they're rocking with that what
about Garrett Wilson I thought we were
on Garrett for some reason we went away
from Garrett Wilson
exactly exactly oh hey we got to get
Ryan his own segment we got to just so
we can see how many time he loses his
his somebody said thumbs down Jalen
waddle
all right okay okay fine fine
all right here we go right let's let's
let's officially get it we got Keenan
Allen locked in the odds are plus 609.
thumbs up if you guys like this thumbs
down if you guys are not rocking with
kid and Ella we need to know in the chat
see Thomas 110 no no no all caps
bro
it's just one just one guy you know
about the delay dot they're you know
like come on I want to win three times
three thumbs down Aaron Jones thank you
Chad for listening on the recommendation
front M flight uh Garrett Wilson
kale bivvy three thumbs down Garrett uh
Justin Ripa thumbs down Wilson Mike
Steve Ritter Keenan sucks take G Will
mg262 Wilson
uh Phil unite Allen four thumbs down
this one is split Hawkinson was a full
though this is split
throw Garrett Wilson in there but we
also like have to do we have to finish
this show by 1 pm Eastern so
okay you do have to decide someone soon
I don't know how we're gonna see this is
split all right okay and then this is
what we'll decide we'll go yes Garrett
Wilson will be the final and then we'll
just take it and then unless they hate
it then yeah okay fine they're all
playing some like Travis Kelsey lock and
piss Ryan off but we'll hit the parlay
all right here we go guys all right
attention Garrett Wilson yeah we got
amaran yeah here's how we should frame
it do you want Garrett Wilson or do you
want like a high juice thing that's
gonna block the hit that we'll just pick
at random so it's like mystery box or
Garrett Wilson those are your two
options
thumbs up if you like Garrett Wilson
thumbs down if you guys don't we'll see
how it goes uh what's this one at Ryan
what's the juice this one so if we do
almond rice St Brown plus 100 Derek
Henry at minus 145.
Garrett Wilson at plus 175. uh ends up
at Plus 8 29 our three leg anytime
touchdown parlay there I'm seeing Thumbs
Up Guys yeah I'm saying thumbs up too
all right I'll see you call it yeah
people my people that's it Ryan is
Vindicated
I would like it to be fair to just so I
can say this I would like it to be
juicier moving forward but I'll take
eight plus uh plus a 29.
we'll settle right I don't know how I I
really want to know how many wins do you
get making your parlays juicy like this
and we have to document this like it's
it has to be documented because Sam
knows we want wins you won't win you're
trying to get rich you can get both I
want to know how often do you get rich
uh with doing stuff like this yes
30 70.
but when it's juice but when it's Juiced
it makes up for the 70. all right next
week we got to get Ryan his own segment
and uh we're gonna make a side bet but
uh all right we locked this in guys so
we're locking this in everybody feeling
good about this
and I will say the The Vibes were just
immacula in the chat throughout so shout
out to the chat you guys brought it
today a lot of great suggestions great
Vibes great use of the thumbs up thumbs
down Paul so appreciate you guys yeah
except after 87 who said these guys are
clowns so that that hurt my feelings Mr
doctor
Ryan we're locking it in so give the
people what the parlay is one more time
and then we're gonna move on yes sir
let's do it I'm in Ross St Brown the sun
god plus 100 against the Jacksonville
Jaguars Derrick Henry minus 145 against
the Philadelphia Eagles and then Garrett
Wilson against the Minnesota Vikings at
plus 175. you add all those three up and
you get plus
8.29. there it is there it is make sure
you guys tell us on DraftKings and it
wouldn't be Sunday if I didn't do a
little anytime touchdown boost medic so
we're gonna also boost Jamal Williams
anytime TouchDown for minus 145 Ryan
to minus 110.
a little boost we're going to give it a
little boost for you guys make sure you
guys go on DraftKings and fill that and
uh Sam you brought us six bets
it did you also told us to send Ryan
back to the chat earlier in the show so
that's exactly what we're gonna do right
now Ryan we're going to send you back to
the chat Brother Sam let's start off
with your first pick can we get 45
seconds on the clock please
uh say I'm 45 seconds it's about to be
on the clock I don't know if you're
going to use the whole 45 but whether
you use it or not we are all waiting for
these six Best Bets go ahead brother all
right first pick and I think this is my
favorite pick of the day will be the New
York Jets plus three oh the the clock
hasn't even started so I got more time
uh the New York Jets plus three uh
against the Minnesota Vikings look I I
just think this Vikings team is just the
ultimate fraud the fraud of all frauds
so again clip that out Vikings are
frauds
um you you know you look at that that
Patriots offense that we saw
um this past week against the bills that
same offense that looked just Dreadful
against the bills absolutely torched
this Vikings defense they had 8.5 yards
per play they should have won that game
the Vikings got a kick return they got
some questionable calls including
overturned TD but that's sort of what
the Vikings have been all year they get
out gained they get outplayed and they
somehow win these games and I just think
that luck runs up the rank 22nd in dvoa
again that is like right around where
like the Broncos are and the Saints
aren't on these teams like it's not
Elite the jets are in that 10 spot nine
spot dboa the Jets the better team Mike
White is better than Zach Wilson I'm
going over and the Jets are gonna win
this game
there it is my man Sam just took up like
55 or maybe 60 seconds to explain that
well but that is okay
plus three let's bring in producer Ryan
because he is how we me and you Sam he's
how we connect to the chat so producer
Ryan we want to know what is the chat
talking about right now
so uh nyh says yes in all caps Mike
White greater than Zach Wilson uh Chris
says uh are these guys ever right and
then Colt Christie jumped in uh and
responded and said Thanksgiving anytime
TD parlay you clown shout out
shout out thirsty shout out we can't
help the people that pay attention yeah
yeah
God sorry no I was just going to say if
they're paying attention and they know
that we're in the green that shows in
the green in week 13. uh DJ Khaled once
said you either win with us or you watch
us win and that is what's happening
right now we are winning right it is
yeah it is that's true you got to get
the producer we got to get the producer
to like get us like our our records and
stuff you know what I'm saying just so
we can like rub it in just a little bit
more but I don't know anyway Ryan you
got anything from the chat if not we're
gonna go back to Sam because he has five
more picks uh there's a question from
Jay Wade that says what's dvoa
dvoa is just an advanced metric that
basically evaluates everything that goes
into a play
um it evaluates luck Factor strength of
schedule everything along those lines
it's just a really good Advanced metric
that I have used you know everyone who
likes their own stats and numbers but
it's just a metric that I've used and I
felt has been very predictive and
towards in terms of betting this league
so look it up it's on football Outsiders
very very helpful let's send Ryan back
to the chat we all know now Sam's a big
dvoa guy he just confirmed it so let's
move on to this next pick the second
pick out of six Sam
are we faking dvoa here
maybe
my next pick I like this one a lot too I
I really do like this slate um is Titans
plus four and a half to me this is just
a match-up nightmare for Philly we've
talked about a lot in this show the one
place that you can beat Philly in is on
the ground their Rush defense is not
very good and that is a problem when
you're facing Derrick Henry who is the
entire Titans offense and is going to
get the ball 30 times I know obviously
the Bengals shot them down last week
riding the ball but I do think if
anything they're going to use that as
fuel to get the ground game back on
track and then the other side of the
ball the Titans Rush defense is number
one the rush defense and dboa so there
you go
um and you know that Master Class that
Philly put on the ground against Green
Bay last week they're not gonna be able
to do that against Titans Titans are
really good against the ground
um I think this is a game that's sort of
slowed down ball control and I just
don't think there's a ton of points I
think that works towards The Underdogs
favor I'm going over today I'm sorry I
gotta do that no I'm not you're good no
you're good you're good take all the
time you need because these are locks
these this is quality dvoa uh analytics
locks so we're rocking what you say I'm
that's two down Tennessee plus four and
a half
two down four more to go Sam
45 seconds on the clock please
talk to us
all right next pick we are taking
commanders moneyline Giants are another
team that I just think is a fraud I
don't think they're nearly as good as
their record is and again I also think
this is a really nice matchup for the
commanders where where their specialty
is is their Rush defense they are fourth
and Rush defense dvoa and that matters
when the Giants want to give the ball a
Sequon Barclay they do not want to put
this game in Daniel Jones's hands but
they're kind of going to be forced to
because of just how good the Commander's
Rush defense is and I think on the other
side like the commanders are getting
better they just absolutely mulled the
Falcons on the ground last week they're
getting tougher in the trenches there
clearly is some sort of Heineken magic
where this team believes in him and
there's confidence there I think they're
the better team and I think they get it
done today
hey they have been getting it done with
high in the key at quarterback all he
does is Win man he's been waiting for
them
can't complain so that's three Downs Sam
three down three more to go can we get
45 seconds back on the clock Sam
let's get to it brother
all right next pick I'm taking Bengals
plus two and a half I I bet against the
Bengals a good amount in the show I'm
sure people are are realize that if you
pay attention every week but I'm sort of
at the point where I kind of gotta tip
my cap like this team is is really good
and I do think they're pretty well
positioned to make a a strong run here
at at the end of the season
um this game is just not that big of a
mismatch then people probably think
Chiefs five and DBA overall Bengals at
six I I just like getting two and a half
points at home on this spot I know
people are going to make a huge deal
about the Revenge factor with the Chiefs
losing the AFC Championship game but I I
would expect the Bengals to be super
motivated as well to kind of prove that
they are still among the best teams in
the AFC that they are Super Bowl
Contender so I think they're going to be
just as fired up and I think that home
crowd is going to be electric so I like
Scentsy
there it is Cincy plus two and a half
since e plus two and a half let's bring
in producer Ryan he's been in the chat
he's been in there vibing with the
people Ryan are you uh seeing any takes
on my man Sam's picks yes love my people
so far the Vibes are Immaculate in this
chat right now uh Jay gamos says loving
both picks so far and he gave you a
thumbs up
uh Christian Vera says Jets money line
with two lock emojis uh Derek Armstrong
said pit plus one is the best pick on
the board
we'll see I don't hate that I don't like
that uh Jason gzz says he's dropping
great wisdom today
uh let's see I know doctor 87's not
happy I can't imagine that guy's killing
me uh doctor 87 said Giants are not good
oh all right I want him over yeah there
you go yeah so doctor 87's in the in the
comments just saying whatever it is
today I saw him earlier yeah he's in
there though he's always definitely in
there spreading bad vibes as we say uh
Mayfair love the Washington pick uh Ryan
underscore Roberto Titans money line it
will be a bloodbath uh
there you yeah all right Ryan I think
that's enough when he starts reading his
own comments like he knows
send him back to the chat uh let's go
Sam you got two more picks 45 seconds on
the clock please let's go Sam all right
next pick I am taking Raiders moneyline
against the Chargers and again this is
this league is all about matchups in my
opinion and to say the Chargers Rush
defense is bad would be the
understatement of the year they are 29th
in Rush defense dvoa and assuming Josh
Jacobs is healthy which it looks like
he's gonna play they are now going to
face the leading rusher in the league
who's coming off a week where he just
absolutely wrecked everyone and ran for
like 250 yards so that is just a huge
favor in in terms of Vegas and I'm just
like not buying this Chargers team
anymore they're banged up everywhere no
Mike Williams again today
um I bet against them last week in the
in the Cardinals covered the Chargers
won that game but they really had no
business winning it they just their
their line sucks right now they can't
stop the run they're a mess so I'm
fading the Chargers at all costs
Sam's fading the charges and rocking
with the Raiders we all know how I feel
about the Raiders but I was wrong last
week I was wrong I I you I think you
said the Raiders last week you took it
last week or no we discussed it if you
didn't take it we discussed it on the
show I think we discussed it on the show
I think one of the audience members said
it and uh I said that I didn't think
that the Raiders would be able to go to
Seattle and get a w they proved me wrong
so hopefully today they could come
through and cash through with that uh
money line for you but that's five down
Sam we got one more to go can we get 45
seconds back on the clock
there it is Sam you got one more take it
away
all right my final pick is not today is
the Monday night game but I'm taking the
Saints plus four and look I'm not gonna
pretend this answer some great team to
me this is just more of a fade of the
Bucks who I just think continue to be a
mess offensively we bet against them
last week with the Browns
um and I know that took sort of uh and
we won but it took sort of a miracle
um for time conversion but still the
Bucks couldn't move the ball against a
Browns defense that has been one of the
worst defenses in the league they cannot
move the ball at all in the second half
they had plenty of chances to put it
away they can't they can't run the ball
Brady is just not in sync they lost
another huge offensive line last
offensive lineman last week with Tristan
warfs he's hurt Antoine Winfield is hurt
for the defense which I think is a big
loss for them this team just doesn't
have it this year I don't think they're
very good so give me the four points and
the Saints of sneaky I don't even know
if it's Sneaky but have kind of owned
Tom Brady so uh I like them again here
they have they have since Tom has went
to that division
they have been owning them I would say
that uh that's it bro that's it that's
six there it is let's bring producer
Ryan back in here somebody in the in the
comments told me that the game last week
was in Vegas the the Raider game the
Raiders Seahawks game can we confirm
that that game was not in Vegas right
the game was not it was in Seattle in
Seattle yeah they they they they they
they just say whatever in the comments I
promise you we're gonna get away with it
I try and be the chat fact Checker but
it doesn't always work uh Al Kaba uh
Vegas money line might be the lock of
the day mhb4 I've got Raiders money line
two nyh as a Chargers fan
I do think we lose today so Good Vibes
for you even though he does root for the
Chargers uh Chop Shop will never bet on
the Raiders so inconsistent uh we also
have fugt saying Bengals are goaded
look they've been impressive they've
been impressive what has been very
impressive is that the chat has been 95
positive today we love the maps
I would call it weird no yeah
during the parlay they're usually nice
but when I'm giving my picks I feel like
there's a lot of you know well Sam when
you win they're nicer so there's
something I love the chair I love you
guys right they love you too hey they
want me to tell you that the chat loves
you Sam I love you I'm pretty sure I
think Ryan loves you uh but let's move
on let's move on because up there you
guys see what's coming up next Greg's
pick and also I meant Ryan's going to
throw his flavor in there too I wonder
if it's gonna be juicy or not no but
Ryan are our friends over at DraftKings
got something special they got the d uh
they got the specials the weekly
specials and I want you to oh it's
actually right there on your screen
Jacksonville Jaguars is taking on the
Detroit Lines we touched on it earlier
Ryan you even said you think this game
is going to be a high scoring game many
points with with points comes passing
yards so therefore we got Jared Goff
Trevor Lawrence to go over 250 passing
yards each my man Trevor Lawrence has
been doing this uh for the last couple
weeks like like it's nothing uh and he's
also facing that Lions defense Jared
Goff I think they're gonna have to keep
up or or it's going to be a lot of Point
score so with that said with that said
Ryan that said Sam I'm locking in Jared
Goff over 250 passing yards Trevor
Lawrence over 250 passing yards and it's
a little it's a little juicy Ryan you
know plus plus 250 plus money is those
yours is those your standards
uh
for a single play sure yes
this is not a parlor I'll take this
all right go ahead give give the people
uh the people your play bro I like that
pick Greg I like that pic I know we're
freezing past it but I do like that
place yeah I like it a lot I think it'll
hit so uh all right mine it doesn't get
simpler than this the Cleveland Browns
have not scored more than 27 points
since October it is December now and
they have a new quarterback starting
today and I am fully aware that the
Houston Texans are not a good football
team dare I say the worst football team
maybe the entire league but they will
not score more than 27 points with a new
quarterback at the helm and a Texans
team that may be a little extra
motivated today to play against their
old quarterback so give me the Cleveland
Browns team total under 27.5 points I
think somebody said before the show uh
that I have not lost one of these bets
when I when I give it out on the show I
don't remember who said that
um Ryan underscore Roberto it might have
been it might have been but who knows we
can't confirm uh so I am undefeated on
the show uh per sources
um Cleveland Browns team total under 27
and a half points uh that is my my bet
of the day there it is we have to fact
check Ryan for just saying that he's
undefeated on the show because like I
encourage you it's it's been 13 weeks
it's been 13 weeks and you're saying
that you've haven't spewed one loss on
this show the Ryan's pick segment is new
it's only been a few weeks it's a baby
it's infant stages okay okay we got to
be we have to be precise and we have to
like let the people know what we're
talking about my man's Ryan he's he's
getting this he's getting this segment
you know it's Ryan's pick and uh ever
since it's Ryan's pick and I think we've
been doing it for like what two three
weeks yeah we yeah about three weeks
three weeks three weeks three now three
weeks my man went 3-0 so we'll see if
the Brian plays continue uh now that
we're tracking it but uh Ryan let's go
to the chat real quick let's go to the
chat do you see anything are they uh
what are they talking about they like
your pick yeah chat chat loves loves my
pick uh yeah I'm sure I'm sure you
wouldn't read any negative comments
about your own pick I would read a
negative comment I bit
uh I did get a negative comment that
Watson's back and I'm crazy but all good
all right time to grade some bets uh
let's see let's see let's see let's see
uh
Joe burrow two plus touchdowns and the
Bengals to win
from trig away
I like it I I mean that's that's I'm not
betting that exact thing but I am
betting on that outcome to pretty much
happen
um with the Bengals to plus two and a
half but yeah I think Chase back is huge
no mix-ins they're probably gonna throw
the ball a little bit more and obviously
that works for for Borough pass TDS so
uh I'm with it
I like it too Ryan I'm sorry I like I
like it too because like how Sam said
that's basically like he's not bended
but that's kind of like what he's what
he's vouching for with the pick with the
Cincinnati uh Bengals so I like it I
like it okay no no grades from either of
you though
uh that's an A minus okay Greg
give it a b all right there we go a
reluctant B uh all right this is a revet
this is a Revenge comment opportunity
for you guys Dr 87.
had the guts to jump in here and give a
pick
Nick Chubb anytime touchdown it's minus
170. I like it he's on my phone I mean I
do like it but it's
170. yeah no bias minus 170 is uh
questionable but Sam we don't use shame
here and you know I mean you did I mean
it'll hit it replay
it's like but to me it's like a to me
it's a b it's a b because it's probably
gonna hit but it is a lot of juice delay
for anytime so
okay I agree uh CJ underscore a lot of
numbers uh Seahawks minus six and a half
I just I don't want to bet on any game
that involves the Los Angeles Rams right
now so that's kind of where where my
head is at but I do that would be the
way I would Lane I like that play
yeah I'm staying away from that
no that's a that's a no
it's a division matchup
yeah man Ritter is Ritter is cooking
doctor87 in the chat well you know I
said doctor87 there was some guts to get
in there we're gonna try and give Good
Vibes to him though we gotta we're we're
getting there uh super banker man Jamar
Chase in his return to score a touchdown
let me get those odds for you I like
that yeah I like that you know they're
gonna try to feed him you know they're
gonna yeah yeah we talk about that all
the time on the show when like like the
Odell to the Rams is like the best
example I use like when they sign him
you know you got about anytime TD
because they're gonna try and get him
involved and I think that the Bengals
are gonna do that they're going to try
and get Chase you know feeling good and
bad comfortable in his first game right
did the commenter leave the odds on that
no but no he did not of course not uh
but I got it
okay I like that bro Jamar Chase plus
money he might be in the same category
as JJ he might be in the same category
as JJ whenever it's plus money in Jamar
chase you take it uh Al Mendoza Lamar
Jackson Anytime tud
that I believe is plus 165 but let me
double check
I I mean I'm I'm the biggest Lamar
Jackson guy in the world to me the
quarterback anytime TDS are just they're
just tough like I just yeah they are so
I don't know they're tough I will say
this I don't mean to segue but I'm
seeing a comment from Blaze days saying
he's new so welcome to the show Blaze
days he's asking like is there a final
parlay we cook or is this just random
lock so before we go off the show we
should read off our final picks in the
parlays so Wednesdays just hang in there
we'll go through all the picks and and
wrap them nice and a bow for anyone who
joined late Ryan do you have all the
pics uh upper uh I don't have them up
but I have them in my brain
um okay I can I can I can cook it up
real quick I can rapid fire my picks if
we wanna Ryan if you want to listen
let's do it let's let's do it Sam you go
who who's ever ready who's that who has
who's ever ready
for Jets plus three Titans plus four and
a half commanders money line bingos plus
two and a half Raiders money line Saints
plus four Ryan took Browns under team
total 27 and a half Greg took Trevor
Lawrence and Jared Goff both have over
250 yards and then what was the parlay
again Ryan uh I have it pulled up here
if we want to go to it it's uh Garrett
Wilson plus 185. Derrick Henry minus
145. I'm in Ross St Brown plus 100 you
add those three up and we get a nice
little juicy plus 863 which I think is a
little bit higher than what it was
before just saying I think it was plus
829 before it's hard the people chose
which we love we love when the people
choose right and uh they chose this
parlay and we like it and we're gonna
ride uh guys but we've been on here
we've been on here for 40 plus minutes
and we still got a crowd and uh I see
Sam's cat is in the back now those might
be good oh the dog
it doesn't get worse than that no I
gotta go I've got to go get her one sec
that's a good that that's good vibes
Ryan That's Good Vibes you know what you
know what that means oh there we go we
got a nice little full screen of of you
know what that means the dogs are gonna
be barking today the dogs are gonna be
barking roof roof roof roof yes sir yes
sir I love that let's get up out of here
though let's get up out of here because
it's time to go win some of that money
that we've been talking about my name is
Greg ivory for the man that's next to me
known as the man the myth and the legend
his name is Sam Richmond next to him is
producer Ryan he is our connection to
you guys we are out of here we about to
go get rich Let's Go peace peace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
together
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]